weird-ass leeteuk's my name is Sebastian
Thrun and this is the third time we have
a super exciting guest with us
justly quite an amazing company that
recently sold to Yahoo is the CEO of the
company called poly war and she's one of
these really unbelievable great leaders
in Silicon Valley that really came out
of a relatively normal education and
became on the top minds and brains in
Silicon Valley welcome thank you thanks
for having me it's great having New Year
as you always do in these talks I have a
few questions prepared and then with our
students speak or students submitted
literally hundreds of questions for you
so they're really thrilled to learn from
you directly how to be successful and
what you learn in your life before I do
this I want to ask you two or three
questions on my end
he grew up in Hong Kong and then moved
to San Francisco what is that impression
yeah it was an interesting sort of
culture shock for me to move here so I
grew up in Hong Kong and then I came
here to go to Stanford to study computer
science and it's been an immediate just
sort of a great place to be in the
center of Silicon Valley I have to ask
as a as a as a girl computer science at
Stanford it seems hard to me hmm
I guess I taught here for a while but
the ratio of females to males is small
yeah yeah how does it work yeah you know
I I hadn't grown up as a programmer like
I didn't really start learning computer
science until I got to college and you
know I did look around and see that most
of the students around me were were were
dudes and I actually remember one of the
the year I think after I graduated the
official of the the t-shirt for the cs
department or one of the unofficial
funny ones was like nine stick figures
of men and one of women which was the
actual ratio it was almost like a joke
but it's been encouraging to see that
ratio go up yeah and I think it's really
important to sort of if you enter into
computer science I just do good work and
then sort of you know that's the only
way the ratio is going to change this
keep doing good work be important
important so great to have a leader like
you in Silicon Valley being so present
been so successful oh thanks and so
visible I think it's really important
for the entire field and so as I guess
your current boss Marissa Mayer was
amazing and very very successful um you
said at some point that your mom had a
big impact on you yeah so when I was
growing up in Hong Kong my mom she ran
her own company out of our apartment in
her house it wasn't like a tech company
it was uh she translated from Japanese
to English English to Japanese so she
ran her own little translation
interpretation business and so growing
up I watched her be both I guess the CEO
of her own company and a mom and you
know she bounced both and I never it
never occurred to me that it might be
unusual for a woman to be running her
own company and I think I always had
that impression so when it came time for
me to consider that it wasn't you know I
just was normal it was normal yeah
that's great which Muslims would do this
company and then you just met initially
at Google Maps we overlapped a little
bit yeah and you were like an amazing
p.m. for maps front end which is the
stuff there's no completely
indispensable we all loved what did you
learn at Google I learned a lot at
Google I think it was my first job so I
was originally going to be a software
engineer because I'd studied computer
science and then I ended up joining the
associate product manager program at
Google and I think Google taught me I
think it's a really special place it's
almost like an engineering playground
and what Google taught me was if you
just take really smart people and you
define a set of problems and you throw
them at the problem and you really
empower them amazing things can happen
if I learned that from Google the
importance of like creating great
culture that empowers people the
importance of hiring really smart people
I think I also learned some
anti-patterns though which is funny that
don't work as well at startups so the
great thing about Google and one reason
it's able to be this engineering
playground is it discovered early on
search and how to monetize search so it
has this money printing machine in the
form of search ads Adwords and that
funds everything else wouldn't you want
the same as a startup
oh yeah except you don't you don't have
that you have you know a runway from
your venture
capitalists or the revenue that you
generate and for us at Polyvore you know
that was something I always thought
about and I really wanted to build a
sustainable company that was a real
business so I was you know we actually
got to profitability it was really proud
of that you became profitable yeah so
you had to make a choice whether to
invest more to go maybe in Europe accept
it at some point
why did you make the choice to stay
profitable as it was too crazy invest
well I felt like at some point the
market would probably turn and I also
wanted to make sure that I get the end
of it you're building a company in a
product but that's also a team of people
that you have an obligation to and I
wanted to make sure that the team would
see a great outcome and I didn't want to
dilute everyone so that was a big
thought in my mind yeah it's great
so portable grew to millions of
downloads with amazing fashion on site
and then I guess eventually you sold the
company to Yahoo um tell us like how do
you go from a small company to a big
company what is what happens yeah well
when I started it was so I didn't come
up with original idea for Polyvore it
with three co-founders from Yahoo who
created the lucrative Polyvore I was an
early user who wrote in to complain
about the product
oh and then I got hired as the first
product manager so you complained to
Poliwhirl and they needed more
complainers I think that's my CD
positive I think I wrote complaint and
then suggested solutions like maybe OPM
should so they hired me is the first PM
you product sucks but here's the
solution for you know your product was
amazing but there's these small things
that are could be better and maybe
here's what I'm curious oh did he get a
phone call for me it was all over email
and then Pasha one of the co-founders
wrote to me and said hey why don't you
why don't you come fix this stuff
yourself
so I met them I really liked the team it
was just the four of us in the beginning
and yeah it just grew and grew and grew
and you know by the time when we sold
about to Yahoo ten months ago we were
about 125 people so we never became like
thousands of people but it was an
amazing it was really amazing journeys
is it because that field is so full of
interesting players as complicated
dynamics I would see him and maybe him
because I'm not a fashionable person I
think you are aren't you I find it hard
to connect to with the thing that drives
fashion by you someone registers
democratizes and get the right feeling
to this mm-hmm yeah I think that's one
of the interesting things about fashion
is you know it's it's driven the trends
have traditionally been driven by you
know the fashion editors in New York and
Paris and Milan Milan who say this is
what you should dress like this is
what's cool today but I think the
Internet has a way of democratizing
everything that it touches so I mean
that's happening the fashion industry -
and what Polyvore does is it empowers
women and girls all over the world to
say no no no this is what we think is
cool this is what we think is beautiful
pretty masculine yeah yeah and as you
know a young girl growing up you I
certainly felt this way like oh I'm
supposed to look like this and I don't
and I I don't there's no reason to feel
bad about its style should be about
expressing who you really are and being
authentically yourself versus trying to
fit into someone else's I deal with
beauty so I think that's the nice thing
about poly bore you can find that niche
you can be yourself recommend everybody
I'm just listening right now check it
out
portable comm we have questions from us
we check one of the words delightful
things always to go back to our students
and have them ask the question and
respond during the speaker for them the
student named Zach says there's a female
leader in the tech industry what is the
best advice you could give to a woman
thinking about starting your career in
tech um I would say the most important
thing is to just really do good work you
might look around and not see as many
women just don't be discouraged by that
like still just focus on doing really
really amazing work and connect with
other women who are maybe in the same
space or who've come before you and try
to learn from them
but learn from from both men and women
I've had a lot of female and male
mentors and it's it's been amazing just
surround yourself with the best people I
think that's great advice for any Y
advice
yeah is any specific things that you
encounter in Salem you have to be more
tenacious or you have to be more
aggressive sometimes
well actually I feel like you have to
find your own style um be self well yeah
you have to you have to lean into
whatever your strengths are I think as I
was figuring out my own leadership style
I looked around at different role models
and found a lot of male leaders whose
style wasn't quite right for me so I'd
to figure out what my own style was and
lead sort of in a way that was authentic
to me and I've had a couple of different
really amazing role models who taught me
it was okay to sort of let my
personality out or not fit that classic
alpha male mold and so I would say think
about that look around for that and you
know find the style that's right for you
scream let's see a student named pyramid
ask the question what one piece of
advice would you give to your younger
self at this point hmm hmm you know I
think it actually is pretty similar to
what I just said look especially nobody
experienced is that extremely young I
should say cut Megan 20 years Ben you
can ask the same question again I think
I was a little bit discouraged at first
and felt like maybe I couldn't be a
leader because I'm a little bit on the
introverted side a little bit quirky a
little weird and I just felt I didn't
fit that classic mold and then I figured
out that I could do it my own way and
that was because I saw other role models
who whose style I could take a little
bit from and learn from so you know
maybe that's the one thing that I would
go back and tell myself be more
confident earlier on in real life like I
wish I'd learned that lesson earlier
yeah it's a few great listen it's
interesting if sometimes people who are
if terminal cancer and then they say boy
you know I realized I should just be
confident stop all these anxieties yeah
myself but some it takes a very like
massive moment in your life and your
case just cool it up with this and then
learn naturally and
very successful he's amazing thank his
question about entrepreneurship in
general from Sweden amazing omasum
every success event when your claims to
have a law or method successful stuffing
it yeah like some secret set of
ingredients what it is do you have one
yeah you know I was thinking about that
and I would say that they're the the
core values that I believe in are now
actually Polly Bohr's core values they
define our culture but there's three
things the first is um delight the user
so the only way you can win in a
start-up you know with very competitive
landscape is to build something users
actually won and they can't just you
have to build something that really
delights them that they love they want
to tell their friends about and no
matter how good you how much money you
raise how good your marketing is or your
PR like if you don't have that like you
can't win so that's the number one most
important thing the second core value is
do a few things well so I really believe
in focus like you know you don't have
infinite time or resource you have to
pick a few things you want to be
remembered for whether it's your product
or you personally and the third is make
an impact which is really what it means
is hire amazing smart people and empower
them you know it's startup sir it's
really hard you know this it's it's
really hard it's a really long journey
there's so many twists and turns like
things go wrong all the time you're
constantly failing and then winning and
failing and failing and they're figuring
it out and 99% of the startups just
don't go anywhere right so at the end of
the day you want to be surrounded with
people that are not just smart and can
do their jobs but you really love being
around and so I think finding that group
of people and empowering them and
working together it makes the journey so
much I really wish you'd been here
earlier daddy be my advisor and explain
me about focus in life what is well you
guys seem very successful I think he's
slowly figuring it out but it's great as
a great answer and I think ya hear this
from every person we interview about the
quality of the product as being 20
Central
yeah and something that quite a bit
julia is asking a question do you think
is worth pursuing advanced degree I
guess you got a Stanford degree in 2011
Oh 2004 for yeah yeah good but you had a
degree so yeah that seemed a doctorate
or master's degree something you'd
advise young people to do or well it's
to take I mean I'm thinking from my
personal experience I'm really glad I
went into industry right away after my
bachelor's um you know I think it really
depends on what you want to do certain
certain fields or areas require more you
know Advanced Study of like theory but
there's so much that you learn just in
your first few years of working about
like how to be a good teammate how to
write clean code that or how to deal
with code that other people have written
that you now have to maintain you learn
so much in those early years that I
think accelerating that is always is
always good so just it just depends on
what field or what part of maybe
computer science you want to you want to
study but I'm really glad that I went in
right away yeah I guess some of the most
famous founders didn't even finish the
degrees that's true although not 30
degrees done this is V and guarantee did
you become a famous phony yes it's
interesting enough and more much ask a
question goes for the very basics of the
initial founding of Polyvore which I
guess you were the first complete facial
complaint I guess but how I mean now it
looks great obvious you gotta have a
site like poly what appeal to come with
their own fashion idea and just spread
it with her friends and define fashion
themselves but as I said back in the day
it was like famous people at Karl
Lagerfeld's one that would dictate with
fashion is how did you come up with
these ideas like how do you get the
inspiration to try something very
different so I didn't come up with the
idea for Polly Roy it wasn't no Sasha
yeah out of the DNA so uh what Pasha did
I think was she was designing his house
at the time and you know when you make a
hot when you're designing a house
there's so many different options you
have to pull together like the right
kitchen countertop with the cabinets and
the tiles and make everything match so
we built a simple visual tool that could
mix and match all those products and
that was the genesis of Polyvore by the
time I got there that idea you know was
built out
was very little besides the Polyvore
editor we call it but we ended up moving
into fashion and then eventually going
back to home decor and beauty and we
just added menswear recently but that
was always that was sort of the the
beginning of the idea he was solving a
problem that he personally had and then
it took off from there and pursued a new
student I asked me a question here it
was related how did you actually
determine if your idea of the ideas was
really in demand tired of committing to
it yeah so chicken-egg question of any
startup yeah it is so important to show
things to real users and there are lots
of different tips and tricks for how to
do that you can use user research and
even if you don't have like a user
researcher in house you can go to
Starbucks and put up a little sign don't
tell Starbucks you're doing this though
or any coffee shop and then like bring
users by show them you know it's just
something that you're working on right
it could be the actual UI it could be a
prototype using something like envision
where you just hook up a bunch of
screens together and it taps it kind of
feels real we even done like storyboards
it look like a little comic strip almost
so that's one way to do it when you're
still trying to figure out whether the
idea is good or not well another type of
testing that that we do at Polyvore is
called fake door testing I have a much
longer talk about it but it's
essentially you don't know if a
particular feature will work or not and
you don't want to invest the time to
build it so you fake that the feature is
there like a clause like a way visitor
boss yes exactly so you put a button
there that has whatever it is that you
were going to build and see n people
click on it if it doesn't work you know
if it says sorry coming soon but at
least you'll know how many people would
have wanted to use it and that can give
you a signal as to whether you should
build it or not that's interesting
because it seems to contradict a little
bit the delight issue yeah yeah you have
to be careful about go there in all the
patent Stonebrook I'm not very delighted
so let me let me give you an example in
the early days of Polyvore we thought
maybe what we should do is actually sell
clothing we're testing a new business
model so we we actually built out part
of a feature where you could buy
multiple items from Polyvore and get a
sliding discount and then we wanted to
see if people wanted to use that or not
and you can make people enter their
credit card information and not actually
ship them stuff
so what we do is once they ordered we
would go and order that stuff ourselves
on like Amazon whoever needed to get
come from and then ship it to our office
and pack it up and then ship it back to
them and so we were able to build this
in like a month
test it for a few months and then figure
out very quickly like no that is not a
good business model for us but if we try
to really build it out and build all the
relations who would have taken much much
longer if it how to return from it once
you feel different yeah we did lose a
little bit of money from that but it was
totally worth the the fast learning it's
interesting I guess I had Astro teller
here and I asked him a question about
innovation he asked a question back and
I want to ask you that question which is
if you were to build portable from
scratch today mmm how much faster would
you be oh I mean wow huh probably I mean
we made so many mistakes along the way
probably half the time that it took yeah
so half the time was just learning and
trying yeah I'm figuring out yeah yeah
that's quite amazing and not just
product things but also like team things
or the right processes to run inside the
company like you know I think being CEOs
is so much about the product but also
about the team in the organization right
what you learn about teams like what
what does something would say oh I try
this out didn't work I moved on oh oh
man so many things um a lot about mmm
finding the right people and recognizing
quickly that it's not going to work or
and why and then you know moving moving
quickly and figuring out fast firing
well I think I tend to be a little bit
more on the lenient side around those
things and just really wanting people to
work out and like keep trying and maybe
you know I think I made some mistakes
there probably yeah I would have been
sometimes Dave yeah that's interesting
section not a command not an uncommon
answer I see also say it's another way
too long yeah okay so Edison asked a
question one of your core values
stresses doing a few things well as you
just take that yourself and the question
is the program world is so huge and as a
young programmer coming up or growing up
how can we know what things really Metra
in the programming world and what it
means to do something well and how do we
focus on those
um so I think there are sort of the the
one thing that I would consider learning
besides sort of you know the most recent
the obvious things like pick recent
technologies learn how to write good
clean code like all the programming sort
of nuts and bolts and basics I would say
that some of the best programmers that
I've ever worked with are the ones who
don't just think purely about the
technical side you know they want to
actually understand why are we building
this what's the user want out of it
what's the goal what's the business goal
and can connect you know the engineering
and the technology with the actual
business purpose so I think learning
learning about that side of the house is
actually a really good skill to to have
alongside the programming here's a
question about socially social goods by
Nishant to ask how do you balance in a
company like poly more the social goods
with the money making mm-hmm well the
nice thing about poly bors the way we
make money is when users when people
shop they click out we get paid per
click so we have what I like to call a
resident business model where the user
is happy because they found a product
they want to buy and they discovered all
this great stuff from you know real
people have told them like this is what
you know check out this this logo this
outside that they've someone else is
created and then they buy something you
know then our advertisers make money so
what makes a user happy finding a
product they like it's also what makes
their advertiser happy so that's a
resonant business model versus like a
dissonant one so it kind of just goes
hand in hand because all the shopping
and the content is driven by the the
community of people who are trying to
democratize style it's good so that the
more social good you have the more you
haven't have to be happy yeah what are
you taking them yeah yeah because it's
about you know would be something good
to advertisers
otherwise you got coffee to users so you
optimize for your users yeah I know the
advertisers pay the bill hmm so the
people doing it is four go into
and this is what Larry Page told me that
Google optimizes for the users even
though the other guy spiracles so
interesting model going forward looking
forward as is your soul of part of the
fabric of Silicon Valley and so much in
this innovative space here but is he as
as great move things next five to ten
years happening answering belly Oh
interesting
I'm really excited about a AR yeah into
reality augmented reality like to bring
did you try Google house yes I am an
owner I did buy the Google glass it was
also good well I think the form factor
and then the apps that were available
you know I really want is I want kind of
like a personal CRM almost to pull up
like and do facial wreckage and oh
that's explicitly what Google didn't
want to happen but it's going to happen
and I would be really excited to just
recognize of your face yeah give a tool
to memorize things and so on yeah and
wearable tech too I think
wearable tech right now is very focused
on like bringing your phone like from
your pocket to your wrist or something
it's like that much closer to your
that's not that interesting like I want
to see your clothes actually like
regulate for your temperature or
something or you just reload should you
don't yeah yeah uh yeah so I think
bringing sort of what we know and use on
the internet into like the real world so
that integration goes to you and have
your clothes charge day by night
inductively perhaps yeah maybe have even
yeah I prefer some space and use just a
color on about the price and so on it'd
be interesting anything else you'll see
and say goodbye you aside of the water
I mean there's yeah I mean there's
there's so much right yeah I mean I love
what you guys are doing thank you for it
make the change of all - yeah I think
there's still so much more to be
democratizing education is a really big
one Hans is asking a question what
advice would you give to someone trying
to create time for a side project in the
middle of a really busy life yeah it's a
really good question it is a good
culture yeah if someone can tell me the
answer that would be great I don't
really know I have not been super
successful at creating the side prod
like I have in my mind the idea that I
will wonder a drop one day draw a comic
book or something I really love to draw
and I haven't been able to make time for
it so I would say maybe the right thing
to do is don't make it a side project if
it's something you're really excited
about and passionate about like go whole
hog just jump in quit your job go
full-time and try to do it just do it
because I Portugal project yeah or if
you forgot the answer let me know yeah
it's true once you take the risk of to
making our main project we do much
better job because you have to make it
work yeah that's true
Calvin asked a question Ponyboy is known
for its awesome community and a
community is obviously great to have
it's a network effect it's also a
chicken-egg thing how do you create a
great community what's the strategy for
them yeah you know I think what's really
important is to like our core value is
delight the user right and we took that
really seriously and the thing about
Polyvore is without the community like
without them creating all the content or
telling us what products are cool or
what brands are cool like we're
literally we don't really have anything
right without them
Pali Wars basically like this blank
canvas and they're the ones who fill it
with the style and the fashion the art
so we recognized that early on and we
decided to go above and beyond we try
our best to go above and beyond for
users so you know whenever we would get
tickets to like Fashion Week or some
whatever perks we try to give them and
pass that back to our community we would
send them gifts like we just knew that
our early users those early adopters
we're going to be really special and
we're going to be the ones who told
their friends about Polyvore and those
stories would spread and so it was
always important to us just go a little
bit above and beyond to you know help
them you know some of them are have gone
on to some of our some of the polymer
members have gone on to you know work in
the fashion industry or launched their
own fashion lines or we'll try to send
them to Coachella or fashion week
because you know really we wouldn't be
anything without them and we're not the
ones who are the fashionable ones
telling everyone what to wear it's all
about them so putting them front and
center like even the poly board brand is
like black and white and kind of in the
background because it's supposed to be
about the content that the users create
they're the brand not us did you start I
mean magazine broke famously started in
his college dorm working at universities
only bidding Facebook at the time was a
human to be Facebook did he have a
similar strategy to find it small its
community within the community or just
open it up and said any country any age
come in we did have it open but we did I
think seed with some fashion forums at
the time that existed so we we went and
like posted on a lot of them and grew
that small base and then tried to treat
those users really really well respond
to their feature requests really quickly
so they felt like they were part of
something special and we treated them
well and then that made them more likely
to tell their friends about it and then
we also did is we made sure it was very
easy to take Polyvore content the sets
that people had made and embed them on
blogs and then share them to Twitter and
Facebook so it kind of spread that way
it was always word-of-mouth driven it
must be that in the beginning when it's
too full every startup that you have a
staff over five ten people and you have
500,000 feature requests yeah yeah and
then you kind of argue and say this is
really important this is really
important yeah how do you resolve those
yeah well I mean you can always I mean
that's what as part of the art of
product management is to figure out like
the bang for the buck and we had a lot
because we had so much input from the
community constantly telling us like
dude we could always keep track of
exactly what they wanted so for every
major launch we would actually read
every blog comment there lots of people
writing like I hate this change or I
love this change and we would actually
tally up every single thing that they
wrote and produce these Docs if like
these are the top things we should fix
and then sort of discuss them based on
that level of privacy they became your
dashboard yeah you need important that
you then made different decisions yeah
data science company yeah we were pretty
we're very data-driven and then of
course there's always you look at the
metrics right like people say they don't
like something but then the user metrics
show that it's go you know it's actually
trending the positive but you have to
complaining specifics
wait I think we implemented every
feature that I actually I thought wow
good time though I can't see this room
for the main my ask
too many that's fascinating
so what's text for your life well I met
Yahoo now we the reason Yahoo acquired
us was you know Yahoo's been investing
in the lifestyle space so they launched
you I was styling Yahoo Beauty but I
think there's been this recognition that
in this day and age you have to have
some sort of community aspect in order
to really grow and so Polly what brings
the community and the commerce and then
on the revenue side we've built an
advertising platform on Polyvore where
you know we've connected 500 retailers
with shoppers and we're bringing that
advertiser base and those were going to
spread those product ads across the
yahoo network sounds like a great
differentiation especially in the valley
of a yahoo and in Google and Microsoft
have a certain amount of overlap it's
it's great to see this happening I think
it's a great great direction to go and
figure out my opinion tested corners one
of things we fascinates me is how user
communities neither voice in things yeah
major real help with the Arab Spring
yeah can communicate and help us take
recipients of products or purchases and
Amazon can leave reviews and all sudden
you realize a good a better product is
independent of the brain behind the
product so I guess it really to see with
fashion it's amazing
how's the Amman sidewalk no this is the
same man responding to we're finding
that you know men men do shop less
probably than women but they don't
create as much
so these self-expression side of fashion
that's what drives the creation of
Polyvore outfits men spend less time on
that so it's definitely a lot smaller
than you see women spending time one
man's fish yes we do a lot of the people
use a making menswear outfits on
Polyvore actually women making them for
maybe significant others or brothers or
interesting yeah yeah if you think
there's an opportunity for people to
make some money yeah we make a great
collection together yeah we actually
chop from it yeah we've actually had
some people launch their own styling
businesses on top of Polyvore so that's
been pretty cool cool well anything you
want to add or tell us any starting to
tell us ah I don't know
I think you haven't told anybody before
maybe
no no deep dark secret said yeah I mean
it's been a really incredible journey I
mean it took us eight years from the
very beginning of Polyvore to you know a
successful outcome and and being
acquired by Yahoo and I think people
don't realize that the average time from
start to exit for a start-up is actually
nine years so yes you have to do
something that you really love and you
have to do it with people that you love
being around because it takes so much
energy and there's so many things that
can go wrong I mean everything goes
wrong along the way and the odds are
just totally against you you know most
startups don't just fail right so you
just you just remember that the journey
is supposed to be long it's supposed to
be hard but enjoy it right and I have to
ask you when you can see when people
that you want to be involved with mm-hmm
how do you interview like what criteria
do you look at yeah yeah well so there's
the culture fit side of things I talked
about our core values and what we did
from that is we identified like certain
skills or yeah but if I have an
interview I'm honest and respectable I
treat you well and I'm gonna figure out
these are you interview people you to
tease out yeah
but they really good culture fit yeah
well so we picked terms like
craftsmanship or like this is something
we care about if you're gonna you know
polish the details from the do a few
things well core value we like people
who have a little bit of craftsmanship
and want to take the extra care to do
things well impact like the kind of
person who steps up and says oh let me
do more let me volunteer to do more so
we identified those things and then we
came up with a list of questions that we
thought pulled that out and then we
always look for is if people can talk in
detail about past experiences that
indicate that kind of behavior then
that's usually a good sign so it's
basically behavioral interviewing so
there's that plus there's II do have the
skill fit so this culture fit their
skill fit and then there's just like how
do they act during the interview are
they like nicer or they kind of a jerk
and we have kind of a no rule so
we look for that as well and then
reference checks are very point one yeah
I agree maybe have a huge number of
Udacity students watching this right now
and many of them come from
International countries some of them are
advanced in life and that appeals career
and what we find is that there's a lot
of confusion and anxiety about the
interviewing process hmm
I'm a spender giving advice for students
how do we better prepare remember
self-confident yeah I think it's always
good to go in knowing the product of
whatever company you're talking I've
seen some people really impressed me by
bringing it like what one guy he came in
with his book that he had made of
suggestions and it was all in the right
fonts and colors of polyworks we paid
attention to the details of our brand
and like came up with suggestions and so
sometimes if you really want a job
you're really excited like when you go
that extra mile and you know the product
you know the brand you research your
interviewers beforehand like that that I
actually think that goes quite a long
way um but you know it's yet it's it's
always kind of a tough situation to be
in when you know you're I don't know
justice building humbly with pleasure
having here for you Leslie talks it's so
fascinating to hear you explain what
you've done and I really admire your
work thanks for coming yeah thank you
for having me we have next Eric Darnell
who is the director of the Madagascar
animated movie series and the creator of
the world's first anime TV our films
talking about AR and VR virtual reality
films that was hit on the shown on the
Tribeca Film Festival so stay tuned come
see us again and thank you so much
Chester come here
thanks for having me
you